There are only five officially communist
countries on the planet and four of them are in Asia.
Well,
already the biggest one,
it's pretty obvious.
It is the People's Republic of China,
founded by mao'setong inmille-neuf-cent-quarante-neuf,
Since then,
it is still the Chinese Communist Party or pcc that runs the country,
Right next to it,
we have the Democratic People's Republic of Korea,
also called North Korea,
and it considers itself the only legitimate government of Korea,
even though it only controls the north today.
It was founded inmille-neuf-cent-quarante-huit and is the
only country on this list that has not adopted a market economy.
Further south,
there is a country known for the war that took place,
Vietnam,
which has been ruled
formille-neuf-cent-cinquante-quatre by the Vietnamese Communist Party.
And yes,
the United States did fight a war to change sides,
but without success.
Right next door,
we have the fourth communist country of Asia and perhaps the least known,
Laos.
The country became communist inmille-neuf-cent-soixante-quinze with the of
the monarchy and the seizure of power by the Lao people's revolutionary party,
and thus the only communist country that is not located in Asia.
It is simply cuba,
in the Caribbean.